let's upgrade store-bought Frozen
wontons to chili garlic oil wontons all
right it's all about the sauce here so I
got my pan over low heat adding in my
soy sauce sugar I'm actually using monk
fruit sweetener and minced garlic mix it
up and we're going to just continue to
cook this until the sweetener is fully
dissolved remove from heat and let's
transfer to a small dish now we're going
to add in xinjiang vinegar this is the
one I use I personally would not sub out
that vinegar it is like the base flavor
of this chili garlic sauce add to taste
but I'm doing about a tablespoon and a
half your favorite chili oil I
personally love this one from Mila I'm
doing about a teaspoon and a half and a
little drizzle of sesame oil now let's
cook our store-bought wontons
transferred to a serving dish Ladle the
sauce over the wonton gently toss
together and finally toss some green
onions on top and garnish with some
sesame seeds cheers
if you're lazy you want a quick meal
this is gonna make you feel like you're
eating Gourmet